it is no secret that the housing market
in nevada is booming some people are
moving into town others
out regardless though it means big
business for movers and madison
kimbrough spoke to a local company
about how they've been able to keep up
with all the demand
madison
yes it's true there's so many components
to the home buying process
and movers are one of them and lately
business has been flourishing
people are moving all around town a lot
moving out of town a lot moving back
into town
so it's just transitions all over the
place what started as a slow down has
quickly turned into a non-stop machine
as moving companies are reaping the
benefits of the housing market boom
and locally triple 7 movers based in
north las vegas say they have been busy
something they didn't expect we
initially thought that a lot of people
are moving out and we're going to see a
slow down
but it's it's been the contrary so we
see a lot of movement from california
mainly the real estate market itself has
affected
definitely us you know between our
clientele and businesses and everything
that's that's just been running around
and it doesn't stop with residential
moves either we have a lot of offices
that are emptying up offices that are
expanding
offices that are going smaller offices
that are moving into houses while they
have changed the way they do business in
regards to covet 19
that hasn't stopped them from landing
jobs lead estimator for the company greg
frawley says it's to the point where
they sometimes have to decline work
we do what we can it's almost like a
first come first serve basis we have
been having to turn people away
in terms of getting their their move
done through us
and it will be interesting if business
stays steady throughout
the summer especially with everyone
getting their vaccinations shot so that
should be interesting to see
reporting live madison kimbrough 8 news
now